I just think it's so wonderful we always
think of these scientists in the past as
being Saints and here he is sitting his
office thinking he I made my competitor
feel uncomfortable and in a way it's sad
that we lose these bits of information
because it makes science seem so much
more exciting we're in the library of
the Royal Society looking at letters
about radon radon is the heaviest of the
noble gases and in the early 1900's
there was still a big argument about the
work and trying to isolate radon radon
is given off as a gas in the radioactive
decay of radium radium decays
radioactively emitting an alpha particle
that's a nucleus of helium the mass for
and generates radon radon is itself
radioactive and decays so you have to
have it as it were freshly made rather
like you can only get fresh meat if you
keep it for a long time it decays away
the half-life of the most disabled
isotope of radon is just over three days
so it's really relatively short-lived
that means if you have a certain amount
of gas after three days you'll only have
half of it another three days a quarter
of it and by the time you come back from
your holidays most of it's gone
in the days that this letter was written
the way they were getting it was from
the decay of radium in fact I read and
this is quite exciting it's the first
time you'll ever seen a glass in the
library because they're strictly
forbidden the way they did it was to
take a glass vessel and fill it with
water imagine now you have a container
of water with a piece of radium metal at
the bottom it is breaking down
generating radon gas and bubbles of this
gas will go up to the top
very small amounts of gas because radium
doesn't decay very fast and so we can
imagine that rather than Ramsey really
competing to get the first sample to
characterize it and because it also
contains alpha particles it will be
contaminated with helium you've got to
realize that these famous scientists
were extraordinarily competitive they
wanted to get there first and they
considered the other one really bit of a
scoundrel and so there was a sort of
competition which is difficult for us
now to imagine and in fact Rutherford
was really rude about Ramsey's work he
says his work that Ramsey's work is
alright superficially on the surface but
when you get down in it you begin to see
the nothingness of it all so he thinks
it's rubbish so this is in a private
letter to his friends Schuster Schuster
was his surname and he begins My dear
Schuster because in those days who
called your friends by their surnames no
first names dunno wasn't right and this
was written on July the 30th 1908 so
more than a hundred years ago the reason
he's written this letter is because he's
really excited he has got a spectrum of
this radon gas he wasn't called radon
then it was called radium emanation
emanation means coming out of radium and
he's got a spectrum and Ramsey hasn't
usually really quite excited and so he
sent a photograph and this is the
photograph so Rutherford to sign this
and he said some of the lines run
together in the reproduction that's the
print and some but they're quite clear
in the negative so he had an experiment
in which he had a small amount of this
gas not more than 0.2 of a cubic
centimeters not very much in which
presumably there
doesn't say so he put an electric
discharge through it so that the gas
glowed rather like a neon sign glows red
in a shopping-center and he then
photographed this light coming out with
a photographic film using a spectroscope
to spread out the different colors all
these gases give a whole series of lines
and this is a print of his photograph
because you get a negative in the photo
originally and then he's printed it if
you come close you can see it says the
spectrum of radium emanation they're
actually three spectra here at the top
and the bottom of the spectra of helium
gas as a calibration so that he can see
what the wavelengths are and he's
written all the way down here the
wavelength of the helium lines you can
see Rutherford has fantastically good
small handwriting or it might have been
his assistant Kay who wrote this because
his handwriting looks pretty difficult
to read and then in the middle is the
spectrum of radon radium emanation it
shows that radon is a completely
separate element and he's really excited
because this is the first spectrum that
he believes in Ramsey claims to have got
a spectrum but brother fur doesn't
believe him I don't know because it
doesn't say here whether Rutherford ever
published the spectrum apart from just
sending it his friend but it sounds as
if he's going to publish it because he
wrote I think roids that his colleague
and I have certainly succeeded in making
Ramsey temporally very unhappy we always
think of these scientists in the past as
being Saints and here he is sitting his
office thinking he I made my competitor
feel uncomfortable do you ever feel like
that
you get one up on your scientific
colleagues collaborators rivals you say
it you say it's a wonderful thing in a
human thing let me put you on the spot
do you ever take delight in beating
people to things I don't usually get
quite so aggressive that's it's known my
nature though I did get quite excited
when I made the compound that my German
friend Friedrich couldn't and I felt
really quite good about that but in a
friendly sort of way I was not hoping
that he would be sitting there crying or
whatever but there are stories of Nobel
Prize winners tearing up journals or
jumping up and down on the journals when
their rival has published something else
and I think it's important to realize
that it's good to feel the emotional
about these things because then you may
have better ideas if you're sitting
there cold and calculating and not very
involved perhaps you won't have the
brilliant breakthrough that you might do
otherwise I don't know what happened I
suspect that Rutherford became more
interested in the structure of the atom
and having got this and so on
lost his enthusiasm or got more excited
about something else because in the end
if you look in the books it's Ramsey
who's credited with discovering radon
though according to some sources he
didn't want to call it radon and he
thought of a nice name he wanted to call
it night on for some rather obscure
Latin derivation but I think radon is a
nice name it sounds a bit like argon or
xenon and also it connects it very
nicely with radium so as names go it's
really quite a good and understandable
name as far as I know nobody has really
studied the chemistry of radon in much
detail but because it's below xenon in
the periodic table there will be quite
an extensive chemistry you will be able
to make fluorine compounds probably
oxides and a variety of other ones and
generally as you go down the periodic
table the chemistry of the noble gases
gets richer and richer
a couple of years ago Brady and I went
to an institute in Germany in dumb start
and they had to display for the public
of a cloud chamber okay we have a call
chamber here and I will now inject a
radioactive radon gas into the chamber
and you will see that there's a lot of
radioactive decay going on in the night
slow it wait a second for the gas
and Brady and I sat there for some time
watching these trails which look really
very beautiful